let's start with silence
silence is one of the most precious
condition for humans because it allows
us to feel the depth of our presence
this is one of the reason why the advent
of electric cars has generated lots of
enthusiasm among people for the first
time we could associate the concept of
cars with the experience of silence cars
can finally be quiet peace in the
streets a silent revolution in the
cities
but silence can also be a problem the
absence of sound in fact when it comes
to cards it can be quite dangerous think
of blind people who can't see a car
which is approaching and now if it's
electric they can't even hear it or
think of every one of us as we are
walking around the city we are about
sorbed in our thoughts and we detach
from the surroundings in this situations
sound can become our precious companion
sound is one of the most wonderful gift
of our universe sound is emotion and
sound is sublime
and when it comes to car sound is also
information in order to protect
pedestrians and to give an acoustic
feedback to the drivers governments
around the world have introduced several
regulations which prescribe the presence
of a sound for electric vehicles in
particular they require minimum sound
levels at specific frequency bands up to
the speed of 30 kilometers per hour
besides the speed the natural noise of
the car is considered as sufficient this
regulations have generated different
reaction among those who favorite sounds
and those who fear the presence of too
much noise in the city however I don't
see it as the noise of the car I rather
see it as the voice of the car and this
is one of my biggest challenge and
privilege at the same time I designed
the voice of electric cars we all know
how a combustion engine sounds like and
we do actually also know how an electric
engine sounds like think of the electric
tramway as soon as it moves it creates
this ascending high-frequency pitched
sound which we called whistling sound
however if we would just amplify this
sound we would still not be able to
fulfill the legal requirements that's
also why we need to compose a new sound
so how do we go after it in many city
the traffic is already very chaotic and
we don't need more occurs but the
streets of the 21st century are a great
case study teeming with transients
cross-purposes and disarray and this
landscape offers a great opportunity for
developing new solution on how to
reduces cows
I have conceived a new approach that
tries to reduce the cows by introducing
harmony since many people don't know how
an electric car could sounds like I have
to define first of all a new sound world
something that it doesn't belong to our
previous experience I did create a
reference for the future together with a
small team we create lots of sonic
textures that are able to transmit
emotion just like a painter with colors
we are able to connect feelings and
frequencies so that whenever one is
approaching a car we can feel an emotion
which besides fulfilling the liquid
requirements speaks also about the
character and the identity of the car I
call this paradigm sound genetics with
sound genetics i defined first of all an
aesthetic space of sound and at the same
time i search for new innovative methods
for generating sound scapes that we
don't know sound scapes that allow us to
envision abstract words to make them
tangible and audible
some genetics is based on three steps
the first one is the definition of a
sonic organism the second one is a
description of sonic variations and the
third one is the composition of sound
genes the description of a sonic
organism is based on a cluster of
properties that everyone every sound
that I compose should have I transferred
to a small sound entity such as the
sound of a car the power of the motion
of music so that sound can move so and
just like dancer on a stage sound will
project trajectories of sound in the air
and it's not just about the sound of a
car
is the memory of my father coming back
home and sound has the power to create
unexpected sense of wonders which
hypnotizes and ultimately sound goes
beyond the human condition because it
allows us to transcend as a second step
we define the sonic variations just like
humans where different bodies generate
different voices also different car
shapes have a different acoustic
behavior which depends on the geometry
and the materials so we have to know
first of all how this car propagate the
sound outside a means of acoustic
measurements and just like a single
voice is able to produce different tones
and timbers at the same time we produce
different sonic variations within a
space of eight words that I defined and
some of them are to me really important
such as the concept of visionary of
elegance of dynamic of embracing and
once we have defined these two aspects
we have what I call the identity prism
which is something like a sonic identity
card of a car and as a third step we
enter the world of the sound design
where the sound genes are composed and
the new archetype is conceived now let
me show you another example on how I
transformed a sound feel into a melody
think that I am a violin player in stage
if I would start to play the violin
I would generate a sound field which we
propagate in this all and at some point
the sound field would hit the side walls
and would be scattered all over the
places and it is how it looked like some
times ago had captured several ways of
sound to hit side walls and last year I
was asked from the Bavaria Radio
Symphony Orchestra to compose ringtones
that they were going to play so one of
them I had the idea to start from this
sound field
I took a section I superimposed the
section over the distribution of the
musicians on stage and then I followed
the blooming of the sound field by means
of three parameter time intensity and
frequency then I wrote down all this
gradient for each instrument and as you
can see for instance the piece will
start with the string section playing
very softly and then it's going to have
a crescendo as the brasses the woods
will jump in and the melody will end
with an harp and a piano planing on the
highest range
let's listen how it sounded like
[Music]
so this is the sound of my alarm clock
actually in the morning and now let's go
back to electric cards and let's listen
to the first example that I had showed
you
and now I'd like to show you how a
potential sound based on the sound
genetics for electric cars could sound
like
[Music]
carts are a metaphor of time distance
and journey of setting out and returning
of anticipation and adventure but at the
same time of intelligence and complexity
of human intuition and accomplishment
and the sound has to glorify all that I
see cards both as living creatures and
as highly complex performative art
installation the sound that we
envisioned through sound genetics allow
us not only to celebrate this concern
with complexity but also to make the
world a more elegant and safe space
thank you
[Applause]